[Music]
in 2003 right after i had shot dodgeball
the casting directors of dodgeball jewel
best strip and jeannie mccarthy my
favorites they offered me a little part
in a movie called anchorman the exciting
job to get but the most exciting part of
it was getting to work with fred willard
i was to play fred willard's son fred
and i did a bunch of improvs where we
established that the character was 12
and
i remember after we do a scene he was
quite shy he would go and kind of like
be by himself and i could see him
talking to himself
i remember asking him what he would do
in between takes and he said
i'm just working out what i want to say
so i started doing that just to keep up
with him and at one point i thought i
had a really funny line that i said in
the scene
i'm a man now i got hair on my chest and
i lifted up my shirt and he he squinted
and he studied it and he said i'm sorry
i forgot my magnifying glass i could
only see one or two hairs there and
everybody
started just cracking up everybody lost
it and it was such a lesson it was you
can't totally prepare for those things
you can't write all the improvs ahead of
time you also have to be in the moment
and he was he was
one of the best of all time and uh i i'm
forever grateful that i got to work with
him what a loss what a genius yeah truly
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
with me as always is
my brother christian i know it's kind of
a sad way though that introduction i
know i'm sorry no
important yeah and uh a nice tribute but
still yeah sad i know it's not usually
the it's not like to kick things off and
fred would probably make fun of me for
this but i just loved him
yeah i know you did too we uh you know
both have to have love fred willard
yeah i sure did god yeah we saw um the
night news broke that he had passed away
we watched a mighty wind and uh i i
forgot some of the
genius of his performance and what
happened wow
but what he does is he's so good he's so
good what a loss but but he doesn't that
and and and waiting for goffman he was
so funny naturally and such a gifted uh
improvisational actor that he was able
to play convincingly play somebody who
thought they were funny somebody who was
aggressively unfunny but thought they
were funny but tried to be funny that's
a very difficult thing to do well same
with waiting for goffman right yeah it's
very it's a similar it's a different
character similarly
kind of uh arrogant
and insecure at the same time
it's really brave really capture and and
that character he played in waiting for
guffman
that uh community theater actor who had
these big aspirations yeah to be a
successful actor
i've met so many versions oh my god guy
in my life and he really tapped into
something with that character it's like
in such a special genius way so specific
and maybe if you
maybe you only have seen that guy if
you've been experienced community
theater and been a part of that
environment but it's such a unique
specific character uh i should clarify
uh people are confused that i was cut
out of anchorman so um it was really sad
to be cut out of the movie but like i
said just have had that experience was
but isn't there an alternate version oh
yeah movie that exists there is it's
called
wake up ron burgundy i think just able
to do that because there's so much
improv in it and um
we were thinking about fred uh being
obviously one of the best and revisiting
those great christopher guest movies
that are almost entirely improv and our
guest today is
another
i would say brilliant improvisational
performer a friend of ours
the
very quick very funny ben schwartz
ben uh is part of a comedy team with
thomas middleditch middle ditch and
schwartz you can see their netflix
special now really rolls off the tongue
doesn't it it's that well once you've
said schwartz already middle ditch and
schwartz it's tough it is tough middle
edition shorts middle ditching shoes
they have a special that's on netflix
now called middleman shorts
uh it's three different improv shows and
it is really
really funny it's so good if you're not
that familiar with the world of improv
ben schwartz is i would say
right up there with the best ones at it
so if you're looking to get into it he
there's really no one better than ben
schwartz
and that's why i think he's such a good
as you'll hear such a great
conversationalist he
uh because that's really what
a conversation is is a form of improv
and keeping the ball in the air uh it
was great to catch up with him i hadn't
seen him in so long i hadn't really you
know we text occasionally but we hadn't
really hung out so just selfishly was
nice and uh how do you know him uh
through
through emmy rossum i think i met him i
was doing a movie called comet with emmy
i think that's how i met him
and she had just done his show his
improv show and
i think she introduced us and and the
night we hung out he was like
encouraging me to do improv
to do one of the shows and was something
that i've always been so afraid of even
though
you know i mean like we were talking
about anchorman that movie
we did a ton of improv in that uh as and
other judd apatow movies that i had done
little things and so i had done a lot of
improv in movies but the idea of going
on a stage specifically to do that like
without any
any script uh
it just was really nerve-wracking and
something i had resisted doing and ben
encouraged me to do it i'm so glad he
did we talk about that
so
so he was also he's very accomplished
not just an improv but he is
a great writer and actor
he's been in tons of things he was in
the show parks and rec that's how a lot
of people know him
and now he's in a new show coming out on
netflix at the end of the month called
space force a new uh
highly anticipated comedy starring steve
carrell and
ben schwartz among other great people
yeah and ben is also friends with uh a
friend of the show friend of ours sam
rockwell and i think they just sold some
kind of script they're doing a horror
movie together every i rarely read the
trades but i feel like every time i do
he i read that he's sold some big pitch
to some big studio and yeah he's he is
just like
he's very prolific yeah he's always
doing something i really encourage
everyone to watch middle edition
schwartz on netflix it's cool that you
can watch it now it's the first time
that's that's
been true so um these guys are kind of
blazing a trail uh and i just so
love that type of comedy um and and few
people do it better than those guys so
yeah let's get into it with our pal the
uh very quick very funny
what else handsome handsome yes
uh muppet like he has a muppet handsome
quality
uh the very funny uh our old pal ben
schwartz
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
i've been thinking about you lately
because well first of all i want to talk
about middle digit schwartz great i
haven't even talked to you about it yet
i can't wait to see what you think i
love it i had never really seen you guys
i mean i've seen you do a lot of a lot
of videos well you came and performed
with me at least two times i think right
yes and and i was laughing the first
episode because something reminded me of
my experience when you
say you encouraged me to to do it um
very gently but it was uh compelling you
made such a good case for me to do it
and then
when i first did it i did my first show
i it was going along okay i was dealing
with the nerves and at one point
somebody said do you remember this i
don't but i can't wait somebody goes um
you know i'm hanging in there and i was
like okay good i'm like coming up with
things and i'm playing the intention i
think i'm doing like a decent job and
then they say
by the way what's your name and i go
[Music]
uh
i couldn't come up with a [ __ ] name
it's hard i couldn't come up with a man
it's so funny that that's the thing that
like you're doing scenes perfectly scene
work is great and then also i'm like
what's your name
rule
regret that becomes the unusual thing in
the scene you're like [ __ ] now that's
what we got to talk about your name is
rule if we have to talk about it now
yeah well which is could probably be fun
but i was i was laughing because you had
a moment with thomas in the first
episode where where the two of you lost
track of what the name was and then by
the way and in that beat so uh when he
reminded me that it was marnie i said i
said that's my sister's name because in
real life that's my sister's name
that's why i should have remembered that
and then he goes that's your sister's
name and i know that going down that
path in the show would have been five
minutes of nonsense so i was like never
mind never mind never mind let's keep
going yes
this is the thing that i find
challenging and and fascinating about
improv is that you have to see all those
plays you have to see the future how to
a certain degree you roughly knew where
that would head how do you do that in in
that case specifically the biggest thing
for me is you're listening listening is
the biggest thing and i'll say that the
show that you did was a show called
snowpants which is usually me and a
bunch of um i get my friends who have
been doing improv for 10 years and i get
one or two people that haven't done long
form with us before or never done improv
before so it was like you know like um
[ __ ] help you said [ __ ] helen hunt jj
blake griffin did it four times all
these people but
so you did it and you came in and it's
it's a harder thing uh for the person to
come in like you it's it takes balls man
because we know at least what it feels
like to be on stage with nothing like in
this exact scenario but it's introducing
that feeling to you guys for the first
time and i don't remember what i said to
you but i do remember when we were done
you loving it i remember you coming back
and i loved it and it feeling inspiring
and i found that the people that take uh
that really care about acting like
acting [ __ ] love it they love it
because it's such an exercise in
listening and responding and and then i
remember the second time i did it i did
it again with you and
everybody had a name i was giving people
first middle and last name did you think
of any names beforehand or no oh i was
thinking of just remember
you know adam
just remember the basics but then i
started going like oh oh you must be
sheila vendercraft and of course
tom stobini here
that's so funny
it was just stepping on everything the
name that you always hear if a kid comes
out their name like when you do improv
for a long time you hear everybody call
the kid timmy every the kim is is always
timmy oh
you know what i mean and stuff like that
but um oh yeah so
when when i'm talking when i'm thinking
about like what's happening in the
future sometimes they'll just be
remembering it'll be like there's a
scene where thomas comes in and he's
like i'm a ghost and in improv uh
everything happens for a reason there
are no mistakes so you're like okay this
is a ghost if i could see any place in
the show when it comes up where the
ghost comes in but it's not as much
about like predicting as much as put
that in the back your head and if you
see a slot where this would make sense
find a way that you know the audience
would be because the audience feels
they're in it with you they're learning
the same exact second you are so if you
can find something that they weren't
they they forgot about and it connects
it i feel like that's always a fun
reaction it shows those callbacks really
yeah
i'm i'm trying to think of exactly that
definitely happened the the ones that i
saw um and that's part of the fun too
even when you screw up it's it's
it's the other thing i love about it is
um making something out of that problem
you know is making something out of that
it's the best um
and i love that audiences are
appreciating it yeah it's crazy crazy
because we've done i mean a lot of shows
now when we do it at largo we usually
get the largo's a place in la that we do
it twice a month we get great responses
whatever but when we go on the road and
people never see an improv before and
they see it we get standing ovations
which was like i remember when we got
our first one it was insane to me and
they really are excited that they were
apart and also the idea is like that
show will never exist again like
stand-ups usually do similar sets or
like they're working on things and you
know what i mean
when they're working on a special is
part of it like that it won't exist
again so if you film it
it's it adds this
different layer to it it adds this
degree of pressure that maybe didn't
exist it's the amount of pressure is so
much because we've done i've done oh
i've been doing it for 20 years i've
done probably you know a thousand two
thousand something insane like that
it doesn't matter what any of my shows
were before these four because whatever
happens it's not like in uh stand-up
stand-ups have worked on those jokes
over and over and over again and also
when they're editing their specials if a
joke if like a bit doesn't go well
they'll erase it
but we can't because it's a part of the
story we can erase like a second or two
here and there like
like we changed a little the the biggest
edit that we did was
uh the beginning of the show when we
talked to the audience yeah we we we
talk and play with the audio for like 15
minutes yeah and we yeah we cut that to
like four minutes because we didn't want
people to think that was the show it's
so good and i i just so encourage people
to check it out especially if you've
never seen improv um
do you find that you get different types
of suggestions too from people who are a
little bit more quote unquote like
improv savvy do you find that they
themselves try to be funnier
that's interesting i do one of the
things we say when we do stuff in la is
that
or even when we do stuff on the road
we'll be like hey don't don't try to be
a dick and thomas and i would be like
don't don't be like
dildo or don't be like or don't be like
uh yeah and then lie about a story like
because we we're gonna construct a scene
if it's not real it's not it doesn't
work it's not as exciting whatever so
every now and then there will be someone
who tries to be funny and the the
audience always turns on them that's
funny yeah and then and then we'll be
like alright we'll get somebody else you
know what i mean but yeah the the
suggestions um we we've been using the
phrase what are you looking forward to
what are you dreading a lot
and for this we there's a conversation
that thompson i had with should we ask
for a different suggestion for each one
and i was like no i think
when we released these as three which
was like the biggest selling point of
when we tried to sell this thing which
was very difficult to sell an improv
show really but when we released it what
were people's biggest reservations sorry
i want to get back to the three
yeah so the biggest reservations were
what's it going to be right and we said
well we can't tell you what it is yet
and so they would come to a show and
they go that show was great is it going
to be something like that i'm like no
well we have no idea we have no idea so
it's hard for
them to because we're not the rock so
it's hard for them to be like
yes we're let we'll let you do whatever
you want we're going to give you we you
know we used almost all of our money to
film it if you saw we had nine cameras
going oh my god wow so in our heads
we're like you know what we rather uh
getting paid uh uh isn't the biggest
thing for us right now is just we want
it to look good and we wanted to yes we
wanted we don't want to screw it up we
want the idea to do more or something
like that well it's great for the
art form i mean it's an art form it's
great for
that in general i mean it's now that
people see it works it's on netflix
everyone's watching it oh no am i am i'm
recording this on the wrong thing you're
gonna kill me
is it off this papa poo toot
oh god you're gonna hate this oh that's
right
sorry i'm gonna change this
okay [ __ ] got it now all right we're
nailing it now
it'll be a nice surprise it'll be like
whoa oh god people are gonna go crazy
for this i thought that guy sounded like
an angel before
man i was so i was trying to impress you
justin with this audio oh man man just
the fact that you attempted it is means
a lot i'm truly i mean that
well now it's crushing it i cannot wait
for you to do my god oh my god i'm
excited
um
you know the thing i always i wonder
about you and about people like you who
are so good at this do you especially
when you film it now and it's on netflix
do you have regret do you have those
monday morning quarterback like regrets
oh [ __ ] i always get that on the drive
home from like if if i did a lot of
improv in a day it'd be like ah why
didn't i say this this would have been
funnier
yeah by the way i get that the most when
i'm auditioning for things i get that
the mo like any time i go from an
audition i go even if i think i did well
but often times when i'm not proud of
myself i'll be in the elevator by myself
and on the elevator down
i'll say that i'll keep doing this me
too
yeah i cannot stand and
it's never too it's never a celebration
yeah always
dissecting how i could do that better or
me replaying how i did it to hear myself
to be like is that what was what was i
doing or was that good was that bad i
always do that still i hate it so it
doesn't matter how much you [ __ ] do
this even after like a show where like
you said you get standing ovations you
get this positive response do you still
have it after a show or after a show
like that are you able to be like oh
[ __ ] that was good
after a show now i'll say at the
beginning when i started doing improv
after shows i would really beat myself
up like really beat myself up and feel
really bummed about it for days uh this
is the very very beginning at ucb
because i wanted so badly to be on those
house teams and any show you did in
front of those people that was shitty
takes away that chance so and it's very
competitive right like at that stage
especially then there was just one stage
it was ucb chelsea yeah and like you
know but it was before the huge influx
of like the huge schools i was like
they're right when they moved to chelsea
that's not the 26th and 9th that that
was the one twenty six and eight that's
where you that's where you think right
yeah i did that there um and i was just
talking abby jacobson and she said i
don't think she got past she and alana
they formed broad city because or they
started broad city because they didn't
make it they didn't like yeah that far
i love that story by the way because
getting on a hyrule team is so difficult
and then like you could be like those
two people who were absolutely brilliant
were able to you know it does it's not
the end yeah but you made it i mean you
so when you're so when you started there
it was amy poehler and it was
were there people that were teaching
that you had already known about and
looked up to
the people that i watched before i was
an intern for classes i was an intern uh
for ascap which is the show where all
like the real fancy ones performed so
that would be amy poehler matt besser
matt walsh ian roberts paul shearer jack
mcprayer tina fey would come play rachel
dratch it's like you know as someone
like you and i who are so into uh comedy
and you know snl it's a it's a dream i
remember every time when i would be down
there and i would be doing the garbage
i'd be you know showing people to their
seats i'd be i was an intern i did
whatever whatever it was
and that's the deal you do stuff like
that in exchange for classes in exchange
yeah you do you do it for a certain
amount of time and you get a free class
but they liked me so they just let me
keep doing it and i just keep getting
free classes so i paid for the first
two or three classes and then i just i
was an intern forever and then i and
then i literally had a feeling i don't
know if it was real or not but
i feel like all these performers are
looking at me like an intern and not
like a performer even though i've been
performing for like a year and a half so
i stopped interning then
and i became a bartender there
which still then then they thought of me
as like the party yeah
because i needed money and i still i
love the theater so much i just want to
be around it this is a while ago um when
was this
time was so 2003 oh wow until i moved in
2009 so for uh
for six years i was in new york
performing improv wow holy [ __ ] you that
and then you moved but you grew up in
new york you grew up in the bronx yeah i
grew up in riverdale like the top of the
bronx yeah and then we moved to west
chester when i was 11. back then what
was were you you must so you were
obsessed with snl you were like a kid
like me who was just like yes loved it
was whose line is it anyway i loved even
though short form is very different than
long form i loved who's lying i loved
snl
and was that it was that the was it that
natural a progression like oh i've
you would watch these improv shows so
you just started that was the dream was
to go and
no it's so funny those it never felt
like uh a goal to do that stuff uh but
when i graduated college i did a little
bit of short form in college in 2002 and
i graduated college and i was like my
dad i had a conversation with my mom my
dad i said i really want to do comedy i
really like i want to try to do comedy
or act and they said okay we'll give
we'll help you out for like a year uh or
two they said two years we'll help you
out with rent in new york um but then
after that like you got if it doesn't
work after that you kind of have to get
your you have to figure out you have to
get it right they were very very
practical where do you come from anybody
was anybody else in your family did they
do anything remotely like no nobody by
the way my my uh my mom's dad i learned
later that my mom's dad wasn't involved
with the industry but that it like as a
manager to one person no way oh really
uh so yeah but but um so we never uh who
was there there was nobody for me to
look at it was nobody uh a tom petty the
actor tom petty who was in pelham one
two three taking a pelham one two three
he was a bigger gentleman oh my god um
and i just by the way i j it's so funny
i learned this like while i was doing
stuff because she's like oh my dad
because
in my head her dad was always a
photographer because he would have i i
didn't get to meet him i met him for
like i think he died when i was two or
three
um so like i had these very specific
memories of him like uh that he would
pull a penny out of my ear and i
remember that so vividly when i see his
face that's what i remember
wow
i love my my gran and my my i only i
lost my grandparents uh very early on
but uh that's the way i remembered him
and there's like different ways that i
remember each one of my grandparents but
wow so but for me we didn't have anybody
we could point to and be like we didn't
know any actors we didn't know any
singers we didn't my mom was a music
teacher for public schools but that's
you know
so it was it was like it felt like it
was like being an astronaut right
right right as it sounds as crazy as
like i think maybe i'll go into space
sincere yeah yeah i so desperately want
to do this that i was trying everything
i would do anything i never slept i
always did
you know whatever so so when you talk
about uh who's lying i saw when i was
interning at ucb
uh the reason why i took classes there
and did that is because i said i want to
be on snl one day and i saw amy and i
said well amy is an up is a member of
the upright citizens brigade so i'm
going to do that
so i went to a show and then i also saw
that like you know mike myers people did
second city so there was a second city
in new york and i used to be i took
classes at both
and second city did not i it just didn't
trip for me the classes were you don't
get to improvise it's more scheduled
it was just extra we were just doing
like exercises and stretches it's a very
weird class for me i think i just had a
i just had a very unique class i think
and then ucb we had first day out were
automatically trying to do scene work so
i stopped doing the second city one i
just kept taking ucb classes and at the
same time i tried stand up so i'm doing
stan i was trying everything wow to see
what felt well it felt good and i did
okay the first couple times stand up
they let me come without bringing people
which is a big deal and i bombed
so hard what does that feel like what is
that like it was and especially at the
beginning when i have no confidence to
begin with and i'd had a show i had two
shows where i did very well because i
had a lot of friends in the audience
yeah and the guy's like you know what
you're good you come you can do this
crappy whatever show
uh and i it was i remember apologizing
to the audience because i was so
embarrassed oh god i was so embarrassed
and i was like i'm so sorry i just came
from work oh like i it must have been
i felt like i was and so i never bombed
with it and if i bomb an improv i could
look to my left and my right and we all
just exactly it was a different feeling
than just me on stage and like you said
that can be part of the fun i mean you
can make a moment out of bombing or yeah
it's a mistake that you can turn into
something so you bomb doing stand-up and
then how do you get back out there or do
you or are you just like i'm going to
commit to improv now
it was me deciding which one did i want
to really try to travel or really push
into and i was really liking improv and
sketch at ucb and stand up it was fun
when i when it hit it was fun but it was
waiting forever and then going up nobody
talks to you afterwards like the other
comics aren't like talking to each other
or for my case it was like
i love the idea of the social community
of the improv and i'm sure there is that
first stand up now i know there is
because i've met so many stand-ups but
at the beginning man it was it was tough
and i'm driving in from west chester at
the beginning before i had a place to
stay so it's like i'm taking two i'm
taking a train in then a train back
trying to like so
it's so much work just to get on stage
for five minutes and bomb and not talk
to anybody also the extra pressure of
there's a time limit it's not like oh
this is what i'm doing now it's like i
have this certain amount of time and if
i don't
make it i you do what i mean what's that
what what's the alternative what do you
after your parents if none of the
comedies
i have no idea i i i try to be a
paralegal or
i always want to be a teacher or
something that like yeah like something
like the same thing that all of us say
that are like
not terrible people like i'd like to
help somebody somehow you know what i
mean yeah yeah no i i still i don't know
what i would do but i i would have said
something like that i think a teacher or
something um exactly and your mom is
your mom still a teacher
she is over 50 years drunk school
teacher isn't that crazy wow music music
she teaches music for k through five and
now she does a little bit of chorus oh
wow she's great it's just mother's day
i'm happy we talked yeah did you grow up
did she instill a love of music do you
grow up playing instruments musical so
like so like you know little shop any
musical that she was doing for k through
five which is you know the most
baseline you know kids learning the most
basically like bye-bye birdie but like
you know the most nothing intricate and
she's just playing power chords and kids
are singing along i love that
so i all those songs so like bobby
birdie and louis
i was never allowed to be a main role
because my mom was a teacher no [ __ ]
yeah so i so i didn't act or think about
acting till i was forced to senior
college i was almost [ __ ] loud so i took
a i took a acting class because all the
football players were taking acting
classes so they didn't fail no but i was
taking action class so i could get [ __ ]
laughs
oh my god at the end of it they said you
have to audition if you're in this class
you have to audition for the play so i
auditioned for a brecht play which you
are well versed in that stuff and i'm
not well uh but somewhat but jesus
that's hardcore it is it was and i got
it i played azdak in caucasian chalk
circle and it was so hard
um but he let me improvise a little bit
which was hilarious because it's a
breath play there should be zero improv
so minimal yeah yeah yeah that's really
yeah that well two things that's such a
surprise that you didn't harbor
ambitions because you're such a good
actor and it's and it's so like we were
saying about improv that's what that's
all improv is it's like the the building
blocks of
it's it's acting it's the most level
the biggest thing for me also was i
remember in high school i really wanted
to do the musical but i was so scared of
auditioning and being told that i'm not
good at all these things
because and i was in like chorus and i
was in all county chorus i was in like
all these fancy chorus when i was in
high school my voice was very high so i
was like a low soprano and like going
like and going after it and loving it
loving your speech your natural speaking
voice was high too
no when i uh it was way higher than this
my voice has been wrecked from voice
over oh absolutely right why i can't
sing like i used to see mine because
yeah like yeah it's dude you know what i
mean doing things it's doing it's [ __ ] i
don't because i didn't train it and i do
certain voices where it says this is
what you're talking about right where
it's just it strains your voice it's
you're not or hi almost all my voices i
do are like young energetic kids
and i don't know how to use my diaphragm
because i never did musicals so i'm
using my throat and i'm just destroying
it every time uh is that so for
ducktales you do a higher voice they
don't yeah i just did so i just did two
and a half hours of ducktales right
before oh my god and so the whole thing
is up here and i'm like come on guys
let's get out of here and it's it's also
like come on and it's like oh yeah so
yeah and sonic is really high also
we did maybe 25 six hour sessions of
that like it's crazy oh my god and then
you have to i remember doing that for
alvin the chipmunks i would need yeah
people laugh when i'm like i gotta rest
my voice for helping but it's the same
thing it and it's yeah it's when they
get excited it's that's it yeah because
by the way that character and we're
always
either fighting or going after so
excited or did you have to sing also in
the first one and then they then they
got other people to do it yeah yeah we
did in the first one and that's weird
because you
uh it's it's you have to you also have
to modulate the voice um because they sp
to speed it up because they but it's
you've got oh yeah alvin especially
remember those christmas records yeah
that's all that was all like yeah yeah
you went to sing in sonic
uh sonic no in dewey i sing a lot yeah
wait who has to be like bobby moynihan
oh duck tales is ducktales it's a great
cast
it's amazing it's david
tennant mcduck
uh meeb danny pooty bobby moynihan is
huey dewey louie a webby is kate
mccoochie
uh tolks's beakley lin-manuel miranda's
gizmoduck my god oh my gosh it's the the
guest cast is like you know alice and
janie's in it it's all like that's funny
it's amazing what a great i love her i'm
sure you know her don't you yeah she's
the best i don't know her really i met
her once but she's i'm in awe
there's been so talented i i saw i tonya
really late um
and i i she's amazing in that movie
she's almost amazing there are
performances of hers that i see that are
like scary
it's that thing where you it's almost
like they're being inhabited like
there's something supernatural about uh
about about them you know like they've
been possessed
i agree that itania rule is such a good
example of that too yeah uh she is
unbelievable in that way yeah
that's cool isn't it funny that we work
with these people um you never see him
you never
you say you met alice and janie once and
you're in every episode with her oh no
by the way i david 10 i've i mean i know
david because he comes in for press and
i'm friends with him now yeah sonic you
got to work with another legend [ __ ]
jim carrey it doesn't get yeah but he's
not there i'm doing it to the screen
like same with you when you did alvin
you were never on set right no yeah
no so when do you meet jim carrey
during press oh my god that's funny all
right we i went once there they asked me
to go there once
and um to do what i had to do like
to do no they hired this great uh did
you do your off camera no no no
they didn't want me they didn't want to
hire this great
because i think they would have to pay
us more
yeah for sure they're like no no you're
a voice over actor and you stay away
from us but um the they uh i had to put
the dots on my face and take a bunch of
pictures and i did the table reads but
jim wasn't there yet because he got
hired right right before we started but
um i went there and uh i knew james a
little bit because i did the lines with
him a couple times so he knew how i'd
improvise and how i'd play as the
character yeah but meeting jim was like
i mean that that is i mean we just
watched ace ventura yesterday it just
came back out on netflix it's he's
he's um he's a magician it's insane
i was very nervous you mentioned doing
like a direct play in college which is
it's crazy to me that you sort of
stumbled into that you did that by
accident but that's very rare by the way
for people listening to be able to be
allowed to improvise while doing a play
usually you do a play it's like you and
especially that play it's like you don't
you don't
it's obviously a college production
nobody's really seeing that play you
know what i mean but my parents coming
to that
uh and when they came to one of my
improv shows i was terrified to audition
for the college improv group because my
group of friends thought i was funny and
i was terrified of auditioning for the
people who were in the group who were
really considered funny to tell me that
i was not funny and i'm not good and i'm
not any of that so i did not audition
till
my girlfriend at the time forced me to
audition junior year of college and
because one of our friends one of her
friends was in the group and she's like
just do it you'll be fine and
i was terrified i feel like i barely got
in and then when we started performing
i'll say probably like three or four in
i started being one of the reasons that
people were showing up and like my
parents came to that my parents came to
the breck thing and that's why they said
afterwards when i said hey i want to try
to do this they're like all right we'll
give you two years because they saw me
already working hard at it right oh not
only working hard but people responding
to you i mean yeah by the way that's a
big thing too i wonder if i was doing
that and i was bad if they would still
be like yeah yeah well we'll give you
six months how about that
uh
yeah
life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
how did you find thomas how did you guys
find each other well i was doing
something upright citizens brigade he
came from chicago and he was um so much
better than you know 90 of the people on
our stage but he wasn't allowed to be on
a house team because the only way you're
allowed to be on a house team it used to
be at that time
was you had to take the classes but he'd
already taken years of classes so he's
like i'm not starting from the beginning
like he was so good
so i said do you want to do the way you
can get on stage is if you and i do like
a little two-person screw around thing
like and we we said we should play with
each other so we played with each other
and we did uh for school night which is
an 11 p.m show on a wednesday we did a
five-minute set and it was so fun then
we did another uh and then when we moved
to la we did a couple 30-minute sets and
then opportunity largo came along where
they wanted to do more improv and so
middleton schwartz did we're like let's
do an hour let's try to do like a real
show and thomas at that time was like
yeah we could try to figure out how to
like tour it and i was like i don't want
to tour it i just let's just do this and
he always he always wanted to tour it
and then
we really started to get into zone with
these hour-long shows and we were
selling out every show and then then
we're like let's try it you guys
compliment each other so well but he
physically he looks like he's going to
be this
buttoned up maybe nebishi guy but inside
he's this like unhinged almost feral
maniac yeah i know he's he's capable of
that he's incredible of characters he's
incredible so incredible
yeah i love watching him do that you
know certain comedy duos it just feels
like there's just such a natural
symbiosis and and i feel like you guys
have been
honing it for for years i mean since you
were little uh so i always wonder how
people like that find one another and
how quickly they recognize the the
complimentary we became friends real
quick we did that show we became friends
bro i saw him perform i thought it was
incredible then uh we performed and it
was good and we kept performing together
was good and then any time i did snow
pants in la i would make i would ask him
to join and he was always one of the
highlights always of performing there
and so
slowly slowly from just that to
now let's do two person more we did two
person then we did an hour long
two-person show is a it's hard very hard
yeah and then because exactly what you
said before like uh i found that once i
did in prep for a long time and i was
doing certain shows for a long time i
would be on the back wall which is kind
of where you're standing while people
doing scenes and if there's eight people
on the wall you can kind of space out
for a couple seconds and sometimes if
something was bothering me during the
day it would come into my head and i
start thinking about it but when it's
two-person you can't you can't yeah you
have to my friend calls it like
meditation you can't think about
anything but what's happening because
yeah or you lose track it's only if one
of us loses track the show is off the
rails i i've never uh known this but
i've always been curious what was it
like doing star wars i know you did the
um bb-8 right you did voice you did the
voice of it in a way yeah so me it was
uh you would be hater are you a big nerd
star wars guy or no yeah not as big as
you i i'm well
going into it wasn't huge like i love
the movies i love the movies yeah me too
that's kind of where i'm at yes i love
the movies i can't wait to see but
ever since i've had any parts to do with
it then you meet people who are really
into it you're like oh i don't know the
name of any of these people i feel like
such a phony
but for like a normal fan i'm like a
huge fan but me too yeah yeah but so jj
to the point where if jj abrams you know
to be to have anything to do with it
would be a thrill
literally yeah it's exactly when i went
to the because in the end i don't know
if any of my anything got into the bb-8
thing but we got invited to the premiere
and um to see my name i brought my
friend gil with me oh when my name was
up in the credits i almost cried i oh my
god
so jj was doing uh episodes with the
music with that [ __ ] i can't tell you
i was like over overwhelmed did you cry
yeah i was ve i was emotional then in
nine i uh i helped punch up some jokes
in nine and so he put me in the special
thanks and it was like me and like
legends and you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on so jj was doing star wars he's
already starting to film uh he was gone
london then harrison ford heard his foot
i don't know if you remember but there's
like a plane
no the uh one of the doors on set
slammed into his foot or something like
that so they had to take a break and
jj's like i'm coming home but just so
you know there's this bro there's this
droid in this that i want that i'm doing
uh and he showed me the drawing he made
which was just like two balls like it
was like these it was like like it
looked like bb-8 but it was like it was
like uh
it was like a smaller ball up there and
a ball and he's like this is what it
looks like or what it's going to look
like and he goes and i want to feel the
emotion that instead of just beeps and
boops i want you to feel what he's
feeling and he goes and i really like
the way that you know like because he
he's come to a bunch of improv shows too
he wanted to produce a special
um but he he he loves it right he loves
it yeah yeah um i feel very for like him
and billy crystal all these people i
looked up to really wow yeah oh my god
that's right that's crazy so so uh he
said i want to feel the emotion what
would you what do you think about you
coming in and uh you say some lines we
so we wrote dialogue he wrote dialogue
from the night improvised and then we'll
send it to industrial like uh ilm
and they'll turn into beeps and boops so
we did it it's crazy it was crazy so we
did it and then when they brought it
back it sounded like a human turned into
beefs and boobs and he's like no so we
tried synthesizer this guy robbie
stambler who did a bunch of the sounds
for a lot of stuff we did that and then
we tried other stuff and then i got this
job called the intervention from atlanta
it was like oh my god i [ __ ] loved
that movie so clear duval yes directed
this i i i you're so good in that alias
shawcat melody she's a melody linsky's
melanie linski won like sundance for
that she's so good enough okay so ben we
hadn't i hadn't seen that in a while and
so she's is the star of the movie i did
with christian oh she i can't wait to
see your movie she's so special i can't
wait for you to see it i can't wait for
people to see it but um i had forgotten
how great she was specifically at
playing drunk yeah it's [ __ ] great
it's everyone's jason ritter everyone's
so good so good in it oh i'm glad you
brought that up because i love that
movie what what sorry and i know i was
doing star wars and we were working on
that we were working on the star wars
and then clia goes you under this movie
and so i said yeah so i told jj i got to
go for a month so when i left he hired
bill hader to continue with doing what i
was doing
and so then hater did like synthesizer
with jj and blah blah blah
and but there's like all that like they
flew me to london so i was on set a
couple days oh and i was on set they had
all they had all the old star wars but
all like that they were able to strip
off all the layers of sound it was like
the first time ever so i would go into
r2d2 scenes and make and like do voices
as r2d2 is a bit and be like jj tell me
if this is close to what you want and
then he'd be like you know the most
famous whatever r2dc scene but it's me
talking like as in a weird voice and
it'd just be like r2d being like what is
going on over here you're like so weird
oh my god so and he would he would just
crack him up uh and we would just like
do bits so we start off with dialogue
and then after the dialogue did that and
then when i came back um i think jj just
figured out how to use like an app and
whatever but i heard that the editors
started using the dialogue that i wrote
to help edit the scene so now they know
exactly what bba is kind of thinking
so they used my real dialogue to help go
back and forth and then to give an
inclination of what kind of they should
sound like so when they do the beeps
they know exactly what to do with them
wow and then so that was so cool
and then in nine jj was showing me the
movie and it's like hey i want this
section of c3po to be a little bit
funnier can you think of some jokes
because c-3po is adr you don't know
so when the movie's done we could still
keep changing jokes i wrote like five
jokes i got in for that oh my god do you
remember one could you yeah one of them
is that and i also had to do them as in
anthony daniel's voice before he did
them for real to like pitch into jj oh
god oh god literally that's what it was
yeah you're good at impressions i'm like
terrible i don't oh i don't know i mean
now that i think about it he's a little
bit uh he's very precious yes yes yes
he's amazing so we we did uh there's one
where i don't know if you saw episode
nine but they all they go into the sand
trap and all of them fall down the sand
trap everybody's there and so they get
up and oscar isaac he goes to daisy
ridley's character are you okay and to
finn are you okay and then uh all i had
in the visual was that r2d2 is popping
out from the back and all i say there
was a i was like you didn't say my name
but i'm okay or something like that and
it's just such like a stupid little line
but it hits yeah it in the screenings we
went to it [ __ ] crushed and i was
like oh my god that must feel so
great it's such an incredible feeling
and then also like you also want to be
like hey i wrote i wrote that yeah i'm
so sorry i wrote that you know
yes
thank you yeah uh wow that's cool ben
that's [ __ ] cool and um
not i don't know how many people have
seen an intervention or the intervention
but uh i have so many questions about
that
you and you're so good in it you and
shawqat you um and you're you're playing
a guy who's struggling with the death of
his um yeah
that was a fun one by the way that was a
movie where i had a scene where we only
had two or three takes and i had to cry
during it outside with a v with vinnie i
remember being very nervous for just
that scene all the other ones felt so
easy because
cleo duval gave us the opportunity to be
loose and be funny and you're like or be
like whatever it doesn't have to be
funny just be looseness with the drama
be losing and that scene especially i
was like [ __ ] i gotta cry and it's
raining we're losing the like you oh
we only have 10 minutes to do this
it's it just builds so much pressure but
it but well you would never know i know
what scene you're talking about it feels
so organic and connected it's really
beautiful work and i've never seen you
do a part like that where even when
you're being funny and when you're asked
to be loose there's a pall there's like
a
heaviness to the character
there's a way man that's so nice of you
that's so nice
that that role helped me break a little
bit more and drama work which was it
gave me confidence in and also gave me
something to show people that i can kind
of do it if i if
given the opportunity i bet well it's
it's a great showcase um
okay let's see okay here we go a lot of
pressure justin a lot of pressure ask
this justin you asked the same questions
to everybody at the end correct yes i'm
forcing you to ask an additional
question at the very end that you don't
ask usually oh okay good in the same
vein of what the questions are though oh
okay all right that'll be fun uh yeah
okay
what is your most commonly used emoji oh
uh great question
it's a top hat and and this this emblem
the the okay emblem because it looks
like it looks like a proper person
tipping their hat oh yes and i forget
who did it someone i used to text did it
to me uh and i was like oh my god it's
incredible it's like you saying like
like it's just saying like it's like
thank you or did i start with the okay
sign you start with the top hat then it
looks like if you do the okay sign
afterwards it looks like the the fingers
are holding the hat yeah that's great i
like that oh that's great
okay uh if you could be a professional
athlete i think i know this but what
sport would you play basketball it would
be yeah uh basketball
still a little heavily invested in the
knicks
i haven't watched as much because i
don't have a league pass because it
spends it just wastes too much time
watching a basketball game every other
day you would i wouldn't be able to
write ever that's true right now i'm
playing so many video games because of
quarantine and i couldn't i wouldn't be
able to do this unless we were in
quarantine and i'm playing so much mario
kart and beating game it's bananas if
you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be wow
oh what a great question
uh and it doesn't health wise it doesn't
matter right i'm gonna ask you follow-up
questions to these things yeah no it's
good uh it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter like am i gonna die am i gonna
die if i know it has no effect none of
these things have any ill effect on you
uh reese's peanut butter cups probably
oh yeah oh god who else said that freeze
and freeze them might freeze them all oh
yeah
do you smoke still
i've never smoked a cigarette in my life
weed never smoked weed really yeah
why did i think you did why did i
because i'm a comedian i thought we
smoked together oh my god that's weird
isn't that i've never done i've never
done drugs in my entire life really
just just alcohol no curiosity to do i
think at the beginning when i was in
high school i had a couple friends that
were doing acid when they were like uh
way too young and i was like oh i don't
need to do that and my dad never did
drugs and i'm like really look up to my
dad
so i was just like i don't need to do
this and then
uh and then i just kind of like stuck
with it i did i don't mind like all you
know all my friends smoke weed and all
that stuff and i totally understand i
love the way that it makes them feel but
i was always afraid i'd really like it
because when i was in college we started
drinking a lot in college yeah and it
was really fun
and i was afraid that if i started doing
drugs i'd really like it and i just do
it a lot
so i never did it probably true it's
really wise actually
uh and and you know i wonder how much
because you're so now i think about it
it's funny sometimes people say certain
things like that you know like they have
certain habits and i'm like well and i
extrapolate too much i think now well
that's why you're so good at improv
because
you're so present and clear and you have
to
have such a great memory you know yes
memory is huge and by the way in my real
life my memory is [ __ ] terrible but
for some reason on stage but i also
every now and then someone will bring up
like
like yeah i was on or like the way that
people used to write screenplays they
would be doing so many drugs and writing
it and they're like it makes your brain
think different i was like that's the
only thing that really interests me
outside of the idea of like that feeling
of what all that stuff feels like i'd
love to understand that but also it's
not worth the risk of me loving it so
much like i love it right because i'll
like if i have right now i have uh 12
intimate donuts upstairs and me knowing
that it's there once i have one of those
chocolate ones it's over i keep going
[ __ ] i can't stop going back and
eating them unless they're done and then
i'll say yes
uh this is something that people often
get mad at me for asking what's your
favorite movie
oh back to the future easiest oh yeah
mine too yeah is that your number one
yeah yeah that's what i go to
i i love some woody allen movies they're
up there what about bob
tootsie is up there but i think if i had
to if i had to choose one it's not even
a contest for me this is the real
question and i ask you in your own
question segment back to the future
three or two what's better two you're a
maniac you're wrong the two but only
because and and
it's funny because i've been hearing
more uh people have been talking about
three and it's it's on netflix right now
i think that's why maybe that's why um
i just love one so much i love the
original so much that
the stuff where he goes back to 1955 i
love seeing the behind the scenes of
that otherwise i don't think to
this is really gonna
maybe weird you out but i i'm not all
that crazy about two and three
movies i like them i like them they are
so far behind the first one well the
first one's a perfect movie i did a
movie with zemeckis uh i did a movie
called the walk with zemeckis oh my god
that's right you played one of uh joe
levitt's friends right yes
but i asked the meccas about back to the
future when i was there hey man yeah no
[ __ ] was he open to talking about it
yeah well like i was like i'm a huge fan
i was like i just watched the other day
and it was so funny i've seen it
probably you know a billion times but i
noticed that you know when he goes back
instead of it being like twin pines it's
one
pi up i figured
lone pine and he goes ben you just saw
that and i was like oh [ __ ]
but i said what was it when you were
making it like did you know it was gonna
be what it was and he goes no he goes of
course not think about it we had filmed
for a month with somebody else and had
to start from the beginning isn't that
crazy and i was like oh my god if i was
on a project that big with spielberg as
a producer and if i was directing and
someone said
even as an actor if someone's like now
you got to do all these scenes over
again because i know i think about that
like leah thompson and tom wilson all
those guys and she's incredible in those
movies she's so good she's so good but
she had already done
so many of those scenes with yeah
i think about that all the time because
often times like if i'm doing if i'm
doing a project that's a lot of days and
i don't have a lot of heavy lifting yeah
i'm just all i'm trying to do is get
through them do as good as i can and
then cross off the scene so i can just
concentrate about what's left and if
someone said everything you crossed off
is now back on i was like i'd be like oh
[ __ ] you know what i mean yes oh my god
just psychologically
like you got to give and like we were
talking about like having to cry people
don't realize that some of those scenes
are that there's some real heavy lifting
for leah thompson and tom wilson too by
the way tomorrow it's incredible yeah
but to but to have done those i'm sure
they were great the first time around
and now say
oh do them all for a month it's one
thing to do a day or two i agree man
it's gotta be and what a risk by
everybody to say we gotta recast and
then for it to pay off and such
dividends is like incredible i know i
know
that's my favorite movie of all time
we'll never be we'll never and i've been
i've been uh inspired by billion movies
since then but it is yeah the movie that
made me realize what movies were if you
had to live somewhere else where would
it be
um i don't know there's a couple cities
that i really like i really like
vancouver i've been there a couple times
for movies
and i've never been to hawaii but i've
never been there but i think i just want
a place where i can kind of like
chill out and uh and get away from the
city because i've always been near a
city i always think like maybe some like
fun like getaway where there's water
because i never get to do that ever yeah
yeah okay if you had to if you could
have dinner with three people dead or
alive whom you've never met who would
they be oh man
uh john candy
oh yeah i just by the way planes trains
and automobiles that's why
i think he's a i think he's a genius
there's no better example of that thing
we've been talking about which is
you know the best actors can can walk
the line between
real drama and pathos and and humor and
like uh great comedy and he does that it
plain strange automobiles better than
anyone that performance in plains trains
and automobiles is
i literally remember thinking that oh
that's an oscar that's an awesome
performance if comedy movies got more
uh respect that would be an oscar
nominated performance
there's a couple movies that i download
that i bought and purchased and
downloaded on my ipad and it's like a
big thing to download a thing on your
ipad because you only have a certain
amount of room to actually download
something yes so mine are back to the
future one two and three oh no back to
the future one uh planes trains and
automobile the movie up i love them oh
my god talk about yeah it's amazing
those are the three that are always
there for me whenever i want up like
because you'll be on planes and
sometimes you'll be in a really small
plane and there's not a video so you
like that's the ones that i'll watch
over and over again so again just the
comfort of it right that's just exactly
correct some of it just watching back to
the future makes me feel like a kid
again it makes me feel like so excited
so ben you're into you're just as into
three you're more into three than two i
think two is incredible and by the way
from a filmmaking standpoint we when we
were doing the zemeckis movie every
sunday we would watch a different
zemeckis movie together the whole cast
we got together
and it was that's cool if you look at
the stuff he did with cameras if you
look at this duff feed up it's
storytelling he's truly a groundbreaking
director yeah um uh so a lot of stuff
the stuff he did with two is incredible
but in terms of like
three is such a good story and it's a
story all in itself and it's i just love
it it's the same with and i don't know
i've been yelled at for this one as well
i prefer last crusade over temple of
doom
i think it's so funny i just think last
week is almost a perfect movie the him
and she
are [ __ ] incredible together oh ben i
don't think that's controversial i agree
with you i i in fact i just
i now i want to watch last crusade
because i just the other night saw
temple of doom and and i i didn't
remember how [ __ ] dark it is it was
so dark oh my god the child slaves and
the
the the i mean everyone remembers the
heart thing but what i didn't remember
the shot of the guy
going back into the fire pit and like
slowly being yes burned a lot it's crazy
it's the stuff that you remember from
that literally as a kid if i haven't
seen that one in a while
yes
when i wrote for robot chicken i wrote a
robot chicken sketch where he was a
heart surgeon now
that's funny
life could be a dream
[Music]
how do you get a job like that on robot
chicken oh this is gonna be such a long
story but it's a great one it's uh okay
so i'll make it as quick as possible so
i was in new york this is for people
coming up i was in new york i could not
get a theatrical agent all i had was a
commercial agent and a vo commercial
agent that's all i had and even though i
was freelancing jokes for letterman's
monologue and freelancing jokes for a
weekend update uh no writing agent would
hire me so wow no [ __ ] and you were
getting jokes on i was yeah i got 20
jokes on letterman i got two jokes on
snl my in my whole career
that's crazy and and even with that it
wasn't enough because it wasn't a staff
job and nobody took me seriously and i
was nobody knew who i was as a performer
it's hard man so then i so i found out
from a friend from ucb that there's a
writing job opening robot chicken they
were taking whatever but so i went to my
this is i think you'll love the story i
went to my
commercial agent
i said i know i've met with the writing
agent before and they won't represent me
may i just ask them can you ask them for
me all i need is their letterhead right
i just need it to look like i'm a
professional writer so i can send it to
robot chicken so it doesn't look like a
random whatever i said if i get the job
i'll give them a percentage whatever
they want but wow all i need is for you
to send this i sent uh i was making
these short films and i sent two of my
short films and i sent the page of jokes
and i sent like five i sent like three
or four
blackout sketches which like quick
little you know sketches i just need you
to send it with it was abrams abram's
artist
whatever and so the my commercial agent
because i was doing very well in
commercials where i booked them but i
would they would never air so the agent
was doing great but i would never i
would make only that one i never like
made money off it oh my god but we got
along with her name is allison quarten
she was uh she was my first ever
anything agent she was so kind so she
got the writing person to say fine and
even before it went out they said just
so you know this doesn't mean we don't
remember we it doesn't mean we represent
you i go i totally get it thank you so
much oh my god and so they sent it out
and robot chicken liked it and they said
can you come to la for a meeting and i i
don't have any money and i've never been
to la before and then randomly at the
same exact time alison jones who's quite
possibly the best casting director for
comedy of all time
she i wrote a joke that got into timeout
new york and she because she's just
comedy savvy gets time out new york
delivered to her in la she saw the joke
a little picture of me she tried to find
if i had representation and just that
week i had talked to like a manager and
i said i don't understand what a manager
does so that person got the request and
said hey you should come and do this
robot chicken meeting in this i go by
the way it'll be like i don't have any
money this will be like a lot of money
for me and they go just do it and if you
come here we'll set you up with five
meetings a day every day and if you get
anything off that you hire us as
managers and i said okay that's fine
that sounds fair so i went over there i
did the uh first meeting robot chicken
and then i go you're gonna meet seth
green um and he said can you come next
week and i said i can't afford to go
back i go is it is it possible for steph
to do the meeting tomorrow it's my only
day here and they go no that's not
possible i go oh man they go just come
back next week and go i don't think you
get it i can't afford that wasn't a joke
yeah like i just can't afford it and so
they said okay and seth said fine i'll
just meet him tomorrow and he canceled
something he came the next day i met him
in person and he hired me on the spot
and when i came home
so i lost my mind i couldn't believe
that i got a real writing job somewhere
yeah well what happened with the agent
yeah this is the best so yeah i don't
know if i tell the story so i i signed
with my that manager who i'm still
managers with today who's my manager
today and so i signed with them and when
i signed with them one that was over
there they had me meet with william
morris because i don't have a theatrical
agent
and the guy really liked me his name is
brian to persia i'm still with him today
he goes yeah we want to hire you for
everything and i go [ __ ] great i
couldn't get hired to save my life i go
but i have to pay respect to the
commercial guys over there because they
they really believe in me so i said you
can't keep me for a commercial they'll
they'll be for commercial and so william
morris is like fine yeah of course
you're nobody who we don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
so then we fly back playing hardball i
get back to the thing
and that agent tells me you got the job
he's like you got the robot chicken when
i get back home they're like you got the
robot chicken job i go nuts and they go
oh my god you forgot to sign uh your
paperwork to be uh for to be represented
by us before you left and i go what do
you mean they go you forgot to sign it
and i go no you told me that so i said
you told me yeah i said you told me that
you weren't going to represent me i go
so i'm going to be represented for
writing by william morris and i've never
heard of them yeah but i said you know
what i will do anything i get uh that's
robot chicken or tnt related at the
beginning i'll always give you 10
because you sent out the package
that's crazy were they pissed or were
they like i kind of understand that but
also at the time you know robot chicken
paid very little they're not they're not
really losing
they didn't know that i was going to
sell seven movies to studios you know
what i mean right right yeah that is so
funny that's a great story i mean it
shows your tenacity it shows how
sometimes like short-sighted
these some of these agents can be like
what it would have been no skin off
their nose to just be like all right
yeah well whatever we represent you and
just if they didn't want to like take
the time to send you out fine but just
just you've already had joe i don't get
that you've had jokes already it doesn't
matter because you know 75 is a joke
they're not it's not there's no money in
it i know but it yeah yeah but have some
foresight which is why
and it also shows me like exactly why
allison jones is like the king of comedy
casting because she's so plugged in i
met her that week that's amazing i met
her that week and then she said can you
come in tomorrow for semi-pro which was
a movie that will ferrell oh yeah and i
auditioned for a role that i wasn't
right for but she is smart and she's
like i just want to get you in front of
people uh yeah and then i auditioned for
a couple roles from the office like when
i was in new york my mom read the lines
opposite me
um didn't get those but she and then
when i moved to la she she put me in my
first ever pilot
um and then by the way only i've only
been casting parks and rec she cast the
original thing of parks and rec but i
don't know if she can she must have had
something to do with that but it was uh
by the way my first pilot was
me jason biggs mary steen virgin richard
dreyfuss and mitch herwitz's next show
after arrested development directed by
jim burrows
oh my god the only time i cried when i
got a roll i thought my life had changed
forever i thought i was like gonna be a
person that could pay for things and be
in tv and stuff and yeah um and then it
didn't go that show didn't go that's
crazy there was like a huge penalty that
if it didn't go they had to pay mitchell
it's a [ __ ] ton of money and it was
worth it to them to pay him money than
to like i could not it's like wow you
must really not like it
oh my god
but jason biggs i remember who had
probably done a billion pilots i'd never
done any yeah i could see in his face
when i asked him i was like this is
gonna go right he's like oh who knows i
was like what he's so seasoned yeah
jason was like when he was 20 he was
like a salty old vet yeah he had already
been on so many pilots and he's like
dude don't get excited and i got excited
and i shouldn't have
um that's great that's oh ben that's a
[ __ ] great story that's crazy that's
cool
um
uh
okay you'll like this oh wait wait wait
so uh dinner with three oh john candy
um
[ __ ] i don't even know well doesn't that
seem like so long ago i was like that's
what we were talking about i know i
can't even think anymore uh okay how
about you like this who's your favorite
muppet
oh great question
listen there's a part of me that wants
to say kermit but i always loved gonzo
yeah
because i kind of i had like a big nose
and he had a big weird nose
so like i loved gonzo and also i love
that he became super oh no that's grover
i love grover sesame street or what is
it yeah grover sesame street but i
always say and sometimes ben people ask
me to clarify um and and they're well
what do you mean by muppet and sesame
street count i always say like whoever
was at the wet kermit and piggy's
wedding in muppets take manhattan you
know like if they were there
i love a fozzie i love uh oh yeah
you've got fozzie in you you got it's
funny because you're i when i think of
you one of the things that makes you
really unique and muppet-like i think is
your your arms are very kind of malley
but they're yeah they're just all over
the place like yeah but
but i always think that about grover and
grover and gonzo had those arms you know
those kind of like grover is the best
yeah
i love it i love a muppet movie if you
could have uh one superpower what would
it be uh to fly i i don't love being in
planes all day and i love i don't i
don't get to travel as much as i want if
i can go to one place to the other by
flying it would be amazing yeah
um if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you choose
whoa what a great one
um
um
i mean a monkey would be fun
yeah me that's mine monkey's mine i
think monkey would be fun i think it's a
little bit of my personality in it too
yes yes that's funny uh so i alluded to
this earlier but if you would you rather
be called unattractive or unfunny
would i rather be called unattractive or
unfunny oh man
i think just because so much of my uh
career is based on comedy would i rather
be yeah i rather i don't want to be
called unfunny because i've dedicated my
life to trying to make people laugh
well you value it and also growing up by
the way there's a
like when i audition i'm never the guy
that's like the attractive one coming in
like when like i'll i'll be in rooms
with people and it'll be for roll like
allison would do this because she's nice
or like other casting directors where
it's like they want an attractive person
and then like they and also they have me
in there and i'll always not get the
role and through weird wording we'll
find out it's because i'm not attractive
enough like the no kidding there's a
great don lake does you know what so don
lake guys love donald trump he's in
space for us i think he's gonna oh
that's right
he's gonna crazy he's gonna he's so
good i would get him on the phone right
now just you could face time with him
he's that
he's he could not be a better person and
so him and i would talk about like going
for these roles and and he go and he had
this great [ __ ] line uh and i can't i
can't i'm so excited to share it this is
all done like not mine this is all his
material which is very funny he said
that he'd be in a room
and it'd be a line of people that like
are more attractive than him and stuff
like that and they're all going in for
the same role and you know he doesn't
you know don is bald and don is you know
like yeah and so uh they'll go in
they'll go in and then he goes this is
what i'll do uh he goes this is what
i'll do so like the people will go in
someone very attractive will leave they
go don lake donale comes in and he goes
to the he goes to the center of the room
before they start and he goes or you
could go this way
that's funny
i think that cracks me up every time
i when i think of don lake i the first
thing comes to mind is in waiting for
goffman he plays and again this is
exactly what we've been talking about he
plays a guy who's like a town historian
who's just uh talking about how what put
blaine which is the city that they're
doing the susquehanna centennial over
what put blaine on the map and it's a
little kid named jimmy had a stool and
he just
he's just speaking as a town historian
and he's none of it is like jokey it's
just but it's so [ __ ] funny
it's so good he's so so he's
he pops so hard in the show i think
he'll have like uh i'm really hoping
that he more people find out who he is
because he's so funny in this show that
i think the show has the opportunity
because it's steve and john to be like a
big thing and yeah and the people who
like comedy will look at don and be like
holy [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is this guy he's
so funny in it okay which golden girl do
i most identify with dorothy blanche
rose or so i think i'd like to be ugh i
think i'd like to be around bea arthur
as much as i can she's brilliant that's
someone that maybe i'd love there's
people asking like who dead or alive
would you want to improvise with and
it's usually like i want to try bill
murray i want to try uh john candy if he
was alive i think harold ramus would be
really [ __ ] fun to play with yeah um
so like again very straight very yeah
like grounded tina tina fey who i love
i'd love to play with her on stage i
think her mind is great i played with
amy before oh robin would have i i
didn't improvise with robin once he he
did uh he came to ucb and just dropped
in a show
no more than once by the way it was
crazy
and then after the show he came
backstage he used to come to student
jams
because he just wanted he just wanted to
improvise he came to ucb in la for
student jams but i remember there was
one where uh i was very young and i was
it was one of my like i was starting to
become part of asscat ucb has a lot of
things have happened to ucb since i left
new york but um back then it was like
asscat was like crazy because like all
these huge people would come and like
it's all the biggest like amy and all
the snl people would perform and you see
seth meyers and all these people and so
um
robin williams came backstage and i was
supposed to perform with asscat and then
he goes uh
he goes like do you mind if i play and
amy's like yeah of course you can play
ben you're gonna do monologues and i
said great so i wasn't supposed to do
monologue so i was like i'll do
monologues so the way that you invite i
don't know if you have no monologues for
asscat i think you probably have yes i
did yeah they introduced all the
improvisers first and then they
introduced the monologist
but because robin was like a guest
improviser which doesn't happen a ton he
was going to be introduced at the end of
the improv and then after robin williams
got his applause they would announce me
as the monologist oh
no oh no i was like and i was like i
don't even know if i did maybe parks had
just come out like it was i was i
couldn't be less of a nothing you've
seen him on an episode of parks and amy
is the best in the world at introducing
people because i watched her for years
introduce people on uh ascat one of my
favorite things as an intern when i was
doing the garbage there was
when i knew someone huge was backstage i
loved watching the audience
react to that person coming out oh yeah
it would make me so happy so like people
lose their [ __ ] minds and so she
would say when they when she had a crazy
guest backstage she would say at the
beginning she would smile and she goes
you guys came on a good night and then
like everybody go rumble rumble what
what what's going on so she introduces
it and because robin is playing or like
whatever a bunch of snl people are there
so people are already excited and then
they go ladies and gentlemen robin
williams and he comes on a stage and he
does all of his robin williams stuff
where he's like oh thank you no no no
and yeah crowd
i mean it was like a standing ovation
for so long
and i'm back behind the curtain waiting
to come out
and i'm like oh my god this is this is
madness and then they go and then
and then uh amy goes and you know this
guy from the upright citizens brigade
there used to be theater uh i think she
has a big robin williams huge drop away
he goes ladies and gentlemen ben
schwartz and i come out and i came out i
was like the only way to embrace this is
and i came out and i go get the [ __ ] up
what the [ __ ] how dare you get this and
the people
you said something interesting and i
love it as just a
saying you said back when i was doing
the garbage
and i love that as a metaphor for
all of the things that people do before
they get to yeah man before they was a
page i was a page at letterman i was an
intern there i was also hired to cold
call colleges for the upright citizen
touring company so i would cold call
colleges to ask if they want to hire
these improvisers which i wasn't good
enough to be on yet so i was out and
just to get money and just to be part of
that theater okay we're almost done
beetles are rolling stones beetles
uh yeah easy right yeah easy yeah um uh
dogs are cats dogs not even a question i
don't trust cats okay i literally do not
trust cat yeah i'm the same
have do you have oh i this is something
i meant to ask i don't ask people uh two
things um
would you ever think about getting a pet
that wasn't a dog or a cat and if so
what what animal oh is this the new one
that you're adding yeah yeah it's a
great [ __ ] question
great question when i was younger we had
chameleons we had parakeets we had we
had iguana we had a rabbit we had like
you know oh we had a lot of rabbits yeah
i had all those things but now that i'm
an adult
i can't imagine having anything but a
dog
yeah i can't imagine no how about you
i have a little snapping turtle
downstairs here
i do yeah star
aren't they very dangerous uh they can
be it's a baby so
i don't know if this is worth telling
but i'll try to tell it quickly my dad
has a colleague who is friends with my
brother like a protege my dad's an
academic and he's a
philosophy professor and um my brother
is now friends with his protege who's a
he's a finnish guy and they have this
really sweet
daughter who is maybe five or six but
anyway this girl had um she's really
into nature and they had a little pond
behind their house and they found uh a
little baby snapping turtle the father
said you know we were gonna let it go
but i said oh but the ground is already
frozen so you kind of can't do that
right because they it won't be able to
hibernate so i said i'll take it
i'll take it off your hands uh so i've
been keeping this thing over the winter
because it wasn't able to hibernate so
long totally boring stories
not short yeah well not not short either
so i now have this
this sweet little finish girls snapping
turtle in my living room that's
incredible yeah um it's it's a fun pet
to have uh but yeah you're you would
strictly be a dog guy i like a dog i
think everything else would be illegal i
mean like in a dream world how fun would
it be to have a monkey in a dream you
know i don't i don't need to be a tiger
king but like i would love like uh
like if it was allowed to have a monkey
and i don't have to worry but like that
would be that would be i mean how many
times do we have to watch that [ __ ]
clint eastwood movie to not want a
goddamn monkey around us all the time
yes or friends also like your
yeah
it makes perfect sense you would want a
monkey and be such a good monkey owner i
feel like you're like i'd be a great
monkey
you'd be fun to see with them yeah i
mean can't wait both you and thomas have
monkey quality yeah we're very monkeyish
yes um okay here's something that i've
never asked anybody i'm curious about uh
you're waiting in line
you're like oh [ __ ] somebody that you
really don't want like somebody kind of
annoying comes up to you and says um
oh hey uh i i was dying to catch up with
you and then and then they say
and then they say oh [ __ ] but i gotta go
oh no you you've already said oh that's
too bad you say that's too bad
well next time and the person says yeah
yeah well and they they leave oh okay
and then they come back and they say you
know what
[ __ ] that other thing i got a half an
hour
what do you do
uh do what do i think about that person
they're annoying in a way in a way that
if somebody were around to kind of like
hear it might be fun to kind of interact
with them but there's no one around it's
just you i do not want to hang out with
this person you do not want to hang out
i would literally be like oh i'm so
sorry dude i can't do it right now but
like if you if if i if i literally
[ __ ] myself and i had 30 minutes i
would consider that punishment for
[ __ ] myself and i say okay that's a
good point if it's my fault but if right
if i don't have 30 minutes right then
i'd be like i can't do it but if if i
already [ __ ] myself and i know i could
last 30 minutes i'll blow him up how
about this i ask you this and i'm not
going to answer it on the way back i'm
giving you a question that i don't want
to answer same exact scenario that's
what i thought you were going to say
same exact scenario
okay so you're the guy you know you're
so you're online you're online yeah okay
yeah hey and so you're waiting you're
justin long you're in line okay and this
person comes up and you kind of know
them but you don't really know them you
don't oh hey oh hey pete gentlemen hey
what's going on how is it oh my god
justin how are you
hey pete uh good good really good oh so
good to see you dude hey i gotta i gotta
run right now but [ __ ] yeah uh hey you
know what give me your number real quick
and i'll give you a text maybe we'll
hang out this weekend or something like
that
uh i do you not have my number no can
you give me yeah
i you know i don't have my phone that's
fine i'll text you right now give me it
and i'll text you right now and then you
could uh oh [ __ ] oh oh my god this is
crazy what time is it uh it's 2 25.
you're joking no why
225 what holy [ __ ] you're joking oh my
god uh uh oh because i thought i i had a
thing at two i thought for whatever got
reason i thought it was one 25 i must
not have sat in my clock [ __ ] i gotta go
you're in line at a grocery store just
give me your number just do you not want
to give me your number
of course do i now want to give you my
number are you ready here we go please
really quick three two three two three
five seven five seven nine
ten ten ten ten to nine okay great i
gotta go holy [ __ ] uh wait it's green
it's green it's not blue do you not have
an iphone i got it no i i don't have my
phone with me and i'm getting a new
phone so you know what just give me
yours tell me if you don't want to find
i'll give you my number write it down
yeah yeah you just got your phone just
to get your [ __ ] phone to write it
down what the hell is wrong with
you uh buddy i love you i am so glad we
got to do this this was great oh let me
let me also say just before we end that
uh i probably meant how many years ago
did i meet you
nine eight nine it's gotta be ten nine
or ten it's crazy
and you've always been and by the way
and when i met you especially i i had
never really done it or done very very
little and you had been very well
established and already been leading
movies you always were very kind you
always showed me like time even if you
were sitting down and talking to someone
and you could and you uh
have like very very famous and
established friends and sometimes when
someone like me who doesn't really have
anything outside of performing would
pass by in a situation like that they
would be very like standoffish should
not talk you would always say hello you
would always introduce me to whoever
wonderful person was opposite you you
always were so kind to me i i and i i uh
i think it's one of the things that
people find endearing in your
performances because you could feel the
kindness and the warmth but as a human
being even at the beginning like
those little things mean a lot to
someone who you know at the beginning
when you nobody like you can't believe
that someone in movies even wants to
talk to you that stuff so that was
always very kind you
oh man i that's really nice to say i um
i've always always loved seeing you and
i always admired you that's really kind
of you to say i i feel like i should say
something no i don't know don't say
anything
just saying it's nice and it quickly
ended quickly quickly ended okay all
right jesus christ we can't sit in this
sincerity too long uh no thanks buddy
i'm so happy for you i love seeing the
special um i can't wait for space for us
and i can't wait to see you again yeah
man i'm sure we'll see each other soon
thanks buddy um okay i'll see you soon
hopefully all right i'm gonna press stop
on this
[Music]
oh god
god i think it's that well that happened
i felt like we were improvising that oh
yeah that was cool
oh man that really moved me what he said
at the end there
it was very earnest and
well he is a good actor
that is true that's true well i believed
it
a hell of a performance ben uh no that
really touched me i
i've always really enjoyed seeing him
over the years and and i made me miss
him
uh a compliment just because he
complimented me yeah i really want to
hang out with you that was very moving
yeah for you for me yeah you know he
still has this he still has not that i
knew him when he was young but you did
you've not you've but i'm saying when he
was a kid i i have known him for a few
years and we've had some fun nights
together but
i uh
my point is
he has a real
youthful enthusiasm yes i think he'll
always have that that i hope that is
really i think special it's like he has
the energy of someone who is totally 14
years old and is super excited to get to
be in a movie or meet a movie star you
know whatever you're right that he is
uh i feel like he could become the
biggest comedy star on the planet and
still have that type of enthusiasm you
know i think that's one of the reasons i
really love talking to them uh and
hanging out with them is because when
you're around an energy like that it's
infectious and it makes
i start tapping into my own enthusiasm i
mean like when we were talking about
back to the future
we also have very similar tastes very
simple yeah do you remember that night
we hung out with him at the cabin and
this bar in new york yeah and cabin down
below and we i i think it was
i said my
four or five favorite movies of all time
and yes he was like that's my yeah
we had like the same exact top five
movies like yeah i think if if memory
serves it was like
sure
waiting
oh my god yeah really weird how similar
our artists were and you know what i
mean it's like your thing with
relationships it's like i like it makes
me like the person more it's very it's
that's very
it's like if someone wants to date me
that that's a good sign for them because
that means they have good taste in men
it doesn't get more eric now i know but
i think everyone believes that to some
extent but it's also like the thing i
mean that does say a lot about somebody
uh somebody something like movies
especially when you're like you love
movies but it's also not necessarily
good taste it's
similar taste so it's like if someone if
you can apply this movie thing to
relationships and you say whoever wants
to date me it doesn't it doesn't mean
that they've good taste in men it means
you're similar they they have taste that
will make a relationship if they like me
that's a sign that
you know things
might happen things things will progress
exactly
i i have a great photo i should put on i
have a couple great photos with ben one
was i remember when we were with
rockwell and
we uh i forget where we were but we like
happened upon a big
greek baptism it was like this big party
this big celebration going on
in in a like a convention
room at a hotel and we just crashed this
greek baptism and i think they
recognized one of us and and we had
these great pictures they gave us the
baby to hold oh not to take home no no
no it wasn't like
in a gift bag or something um
a gift papoose um oh yeah we didn't say
that he was on house of lies for all
those oh yeah that's oh my god yeah i
got so excited by an intervention the
movie the i mean the intervention
uh because i just love that movie so
much and it's something that very
i don't think a lot of people have seen
people she's really good at that that's
the thing about him and i know you
weren't just blowing smoke up his ass
when you said this to him that
when you said that he was actually a
really
um grounded
natural dramatic actor
i i agree i think he really is and
that's pretty rare someone who can
because he's obviously capable of being
extremely
broad and big and play these heightened
muppet-like muppet-like characters yeah
but he's also capable of
delivering a real nuanced subtle
performance i mean i guess adam sandler
doesn't there are people who do that are
very caring who he talks about yeah if
you want to see what we're talking about
you and and also other great
performances i mentioned in the
interview but chris and i just
we were so blown away by what melanie
linski did in the movie we directed uh
and melanie is just fantastic in clea's
movie you got to see it the intervention
i think it's on amazon here's a
difference between us and we're just
talking about our similarities here's
the difference he is about a million
times more ambitious and driven
than i will ever be in my life same same
it's incredible this story he told about
getting the letterhead oh my god he just
someone who like genuinely wanted
something so badly you know and was
willing to do anything it took to to
achieve those dreams it's admirable yeah
i was thinking about ben in when i was
hearing him he was hearing that uh back
that if he were to do anything else if
he had put his mind to anything else he
would have succeeded with the
combination that he has of being
bright and quick on his feet right being
ambitious and driven that combination of
of traits is like what what what can't
you do exactly i mean as long as you
have some skill and he also happens to
have a skill which is
he's funny and he's a good actor so i
didn't know that about him that he
didn't harbor ambitions to be an actor
that surprised that surprised him until
his senior year of college especially
because he wanted so badly to be on snl
as a kid i know
you'd think that he would have
tried doing the plays but he also it's
also the same person who didn't
want to audition for his um college
improv
club team because he was afraid of
people telling me he's not funny because
his friend and i know that feeling i
know that
oh my god your group of friends
think a certain way about you and you
also don't want to let them down right
and you don't get anointed the funny
ones exactly you don't want to be
potentially exposed as
fraudulent in any way yeah and and when
you audition for something like it's
these other people's opinion about
what's funny and
and they're the ones judging you and he
said he had a difficult time doing that
i really admired also how open he was
how honest he was about about things
like that
but i think specifically with improv you
have to be
open and honest and and be able to like
access a very
truthful part of yourself which is why
for anyone who's seen the first episode
of middleton schwartz there's that
moment he references where he
they get lost in
who they how they've named each other
like what their names are and he comes
up with marnie marnie gets mentioned and
it's ben's actual sister's name and ben
just happened to this is something else
that i think is really cool he happened
to know he could
see the next few moves um which is why
he tried to redirect the improv
chess player
exactly exactly and you're seeing the
whole board
yeah i think he's been doing it for so
long i mean he said what do you say
right he's done thousands of shows at
this point
so the comfort level he must have on
stage even though he did say the
pressure as comfortable as he is and as
seasoned as he is at improv the pressure
of doing a netflix special you know it's
unlike any improv experience i bet you
normally have because it's now it exists
permanently for everyone to see
the pressure that must exist and other
than maybe jazz music there's really no
other art form that exists in that way
where every single show is is different
completely
different the one thing i can relate it
to is doing a play the freedom of doing
a play i mean it's scary and fun it's a
high-wire act you go out there and
you hope for the best anything can
happen but if something does happen it's
like
oh man you you recover you deal with it
and um and and
no one's ever no no
no one's going to know really except for
the audience it's right a singular
experience but it's the same words every
night and yeah
if dave matthews band
play has played a million concerts and
i'm sure he changes up the set list on a
nightly basis
up in the morning but it's the same
songs you know and it's a different
performance every time sure but it's
this is completely brand new every time
so
it must be scary to
have one of those
experiences captured on film i know it
must be
i i
can't imagine because god because like
what if you and i know they have a lot
of cameras going but what if you mess up
what if that's the thing it's always the
what-ifs and especially for somebody who
has struggled with insecurity and
uh self-doubt and
you know it's got to be
nerve-wracking
but also thrilling when it's working i i
can also say this like when it is on and
i've had moments like this
i've experienced it there's
no better feeling but also the
difference between doing a two-person
improv
versus uh an eight-person impression
yeah you talked about that's interesting
too you can go into like you can kind of
detach a little bit right from here and
there but when it's just the two of you
on stage oh man you have to be
completely focused the whole time yeah
or else it
like really falls apart yeah i love
seeing improv shows and and even if when
it's not working it's it's admirable
when they hang in there uh and and it's
always like upsetting to me when they
throw each other under the bus and but
you won't see that in middle ditch in
schwartz i'm surprised he's never smoked
weed i am too i was
very smart because i also thought i'd
smoked with him
i mean we've gone out we've that's how
much weed you've smoked is that
forgotten that you haven't smoked with
him well i should maybe take a page out
of ben's playbook
i
thought it was funny that you started
the lightning round earlier than you've
ever started it it was like halfway
through the interview and
and so much conversation came
out of those questions yeah
and if you think about it that makes
perfect sense considering what he does
oh long form improv where exactly this
one suggestion like what's your favorite
emoji will
lead or could lead to you know it's not
15 minutes of
you know yeah
it's like a marathon round it's not a
lightning round with somebody like that
but you see how he could why he's good
at
it
he just needs a ball in the air yeah and
he all he needs is a little kernel it's
almost like and i like his excitement
when he gets something you know i mean
how many times did he say those
questions like oh oh i like that or like
he's got kid energy energy yeah it's
really infectious real enthusiastic
energy yeah um at one point you tell me
his muppet arms and thankfully he wasn't
offended by that because
i think i might be oh really
no he because when you think of muppet
arms not only do you think of them being
flaily and gangly but they're also just
real thin the same length from top to
bottom right i didn't
maybe think that if you didn't qualify
at all you were like you have muppet
arms and you just like let it sit sit
out there and he was like
yeah i do i do i yeah he does have
muppet arms and but he uses them
to great effect i mean like i meant it
in the best way but but i yeah i can
i can understand that it might have come
off as slightly insulting you were and
that's a good question that you
improvised um about the pet oh yeah what
pet would you pick yeah i like that
question i did too what would you pick
uh a turtle well you were talking about
oh yeah star your turtle a tortoise not
to see the thing with star is that um
she's in the
she's in the water and
i've been feeding her worms which is
like
not my favorite thing to do every day is
to like dig up worms
every day i try to i try to you're such
a good turtle owner yeah
yeah well
uh she's so she's cute i love little
baby turtles but um you know one day
she'll be quite a she'll be a beast you
told the story of how you see them
remember when i i carried that adult
snapping journal across the street i'm
so mad that you weren't filming that
christian took a he just started filming
at the tail end of it i meant to he
meant to i think i pressed photo into
the video but i felt so proud that i
like picked this thing up with my hand i
mean don't you shouldn't do i i picked
it up from the back of its shell to
carry it across the street and the whole
time i was thinking like
i thought i was so heroic i'm doing this
thing a favor and it's like
it was trying to like snap at me he was
trying to bite me uh and they're very
long necks they could have bit a finger
off they could have but i know how to
hold them and there was this big kind of
like uh trucker guy who had also stopped
a huge guy and and he's like whoa whoa
whoa don't pick that up he was like hey
man put some gloves on or something i
was like i got this and i felt really uh
macho felt like a man yep yeah and the
whole time the turtle's like
snapping at me it's not making that
sound you told the story of how you
acquired star and you said oh it's
probably sounded a little creepy you
said so now i have this sweet little
finish girls snapping turtle in my
living room
and i thought god if i had a nickel for
every time i heard that sentence in my
life
so now i have this sweet little finished
girls snapping turtle in my living room
you'd have nearly six cents
yeah i don't think i've ever said that
all right i know i have never said that
i don't think
yeah they're the best maybe a sweet
little norwegian girl
right
dutch girl yes uh yeah the slaughter
makers shout out they're just the best
um and i have to actually
put that thing back in the pond star
that thick star i'm sorry how dare you
sorry
sorry that's why i haven't been wanting
to feed it um just like pellets or like
pet
turtle food because i want to i want to
start a you know you want to learn how
to acclimate yeah yeah because i don't
want to keep it
too long hey let's read a letter okay
halfway down all right sophie sophie
nice name
subject is uh a well yes a would you
rather update from a second grade
teacher and her class whoa
great dear justin christian i'm a second
grade teacher in a small town outside of
eugene oregon i have been an avid
listener of the show since day one whoa
thanks sophie listening to your show and
the quarantine updates have made this
difficult time a lot better
covet and distance learning has made it
really tough to be a teacher right now i
became a teacher to bring some light
into the lives of students who may not
have any well
not being able to see the kiddos in my
classes made that extremely hard it's
even harder knowing many of my students
are quarantined without enough food or
in a place where they don't feel safe
i have been working with students and
overworked parents parents every day and
we are all struggling trying to get my
class of seven-year-olds logged in and
using the internet has been rough on a
brighter note oh my god can you imagine
on a brighter note i get to zoom with my
whole class of 23 kids every week i was
did they do that once a week is that i
thought it was every other day i thought
i was inspired to continue your game of
would you rather with them oh thank you
sophie they absolutely love it
that's amazing one student said it was
the best part of their week
oh boy
today i asked them if they would rather
eat broccoli for every meal or wear
or wear garbage shoes
for the rest of their lives i'm proud to
say that 99 of my students would rather
eat broccoli good thank god yeah thank
you now i mean the kid who wants to work
hard yeah
now i have hope in the future yeah i
wish you guys could see the laughter on
their little faces in such a trying time
i wish i could too me too thank you for
helping keep my class and myself
entertained and laughing during this
time thank you sophie and speaking of uh
kids and parents who are having a rough
time there's a great organization we
talked about called no kid hungry uh
it's on my instagram and my bio if you
want to
donate and have me do a video it's been
so fun doing these videos on cameo uh
all the money goes to no kid hungry it's
a really fun thing so
and a selfish thing too and i get to
hear you do them all day long so it's
fun for me too
i try to rope you into them sometimes um
yeah uh thanks sophie that's that's
really funny thank you to sophie and
thank you to the hilarious ah
ben shorts great taste in movies yeah
in fact that night i was texting with
ben and i was like i'm all ready to see
back to the future i was gonna watch two
and three i need to watch the third one
again it's been a few years since i've
seen that but yeah me too i would say my
order it pretty clearly is one two then
three yeah me too but i don't wanna you
know the problem with knowing
you have such similar taste as ben yeah
yeah
it did motivate me to watch it again i
will say
that my memory of three
is that the big problem with it is that
doc brown gets too [ __ ] weird well he
gets too romantic not only romantic but
too
wild you know he gets too like
i have a crush on them it's too it's too
weird
any who thank you to ben thank you to
sophie and if you guys want to write in
like sophie wrote in we love hearing
from you
yes our email address is justin please
do the honor here we go life is short at
wondery.com it's not here we go life is
short all right sorry it's just here we
go dot dot
now life is short at wondering.com
yes we love hearing from you we love
would you rather would you rather's or
oh and if you happen to read would you
rather to your whole classroom of uh
seven-year-olds please film it yes for
the love of god film it and tag us in it
tag i ran out of breath tig
yeah we like hearing how you make the
most out of your life and uh do
yourselves a favor watch middle ditch
and schwartz watch the intervention and
definitely definitely watch
a great fred willard performance this
week uh to honor his memory um i would
say first and foremost waiting for
goffman it does not get any better in my
opinion yeah just um
the best one of the best of all time uh
we're lucky to have him and his
performances so uh
yeah we'll see you guys soon
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's produced by you christian
long and megan monica i almost paused to
let her do it
our senior producer michelle miesh lands
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
and ernan lopez for wondering see you
soon here uh talk to you soon oh and
here's a voice memo oh yeah bye
[Music]
let's start right out hey what happened
as you know back in 1970
i started on a series called what
happened and every time something go
wrong i would look at the camera and say
hey what happened
we had a lot of fun with that a lot of
other catch phrases i got a real red
wagon
and uh
i can't do my work
and i believe i was the first one to use
the phrase
i don't think so
but it only lasted a year and that's
good because that's how you establish a
cult so i was on stage doing all my
shtick you know hey what happened and i
can't do my work and if someone would
heckle me there they'd say are you gonna
be on stage all night i would say that's
right that'd crack up the audience but i
noticed the guy sitting down front with
a long face nothing got to him so i
turned to the lady next to him i said
would you hold your mirror up in front
of his nose to see if he's still
breathing
to see in fact if there's a reflection
so he started to smile
after the show i go down and introduce
myself his name is george mitchell
he had been with a group called the main
street singers now i was never into folk
music i'd
worked some bills with some folkies you
know put them in the cell with a long
hose on them put them in a cell with a
long hose on them and i used to say he's
got a long enough hose and he's going to
have a lot of friends in the shower room
folk audiences hated that joke
but i said to george i said seriously uh
you put up some great numbers if you
reform your group i can send you out on
the starfish cruise lines together we
could make a fortune and you will have a
ball they used to go out come back they
had a great time
uh except a couple of cruises dysentery
broke out on the ship i was not there
you do not want to be on a cruise ship
when dysentery breaks out and be
knocking on the men's room door and say
will you be coming out soon and here i
don't think so
you